-Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-winning actor
you know from films
such as "Forrest Gump,"
"Philadelphia," "Castaway,"
"Apollo 13," and so much more.
He stars in "A Man Called Otto,"
which is in select theaters now
and is playing everywhere
this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-So press in on the clutch
and give it a little gas.
Slowly let out on the --
oh, you're not in gear.
[ Horn honking ]
Look, don't --
you don't have to turn the key.
-Aah!
-Go!
-Just press --
-Oh, my God.
[ Horn honking ]
-Press on --
-[ Speaking in Spanish ]
-Slowly let out on the clutch
and press on the gas.
[ Horn honking ]
Now you listen to me.
You have given birth
to two children.
You learned a new language.
You will have no problem
learning how to drive.
My God, the world
is full of complete idiots
who have managed
to figure it out,
and you are not
a complete idiot.
So clutch, shift, gas, drive.
-Please welcome back to the show
Tom Hanks, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You're excited.
-I'm very excited by --
I'm very excited
by The Strokes, man.
It's not often you -- how many
guitars are in The Strokes?
-Two guitars.
-Two guitars and the drums.
There you go.
That's all you need, baby.
That's Cream, man.
That is Cream, as in the Eric --
You know.
-Yeah, yeah.
The old Cream, not the --
-I'm so excited about this,
that just for -- okay.
You're gonna
have to make a decision.
-Here is one lottery ticket
for the Powerball.
I have one more.
Now, this is worth $2 billion.
-Right.
-One of these will be yours.
The other one
will go to the band.
-Okay.
-Which one do you want?
-Oh, interesting.
-Are you feeling lucky?
-I'm gonna take this one.
-All right!
-And I'm gonna
give that one to the band.
-All right.
-It would be such --
You'd think it'd be a burn
if they won,
but I would be so happy
'cause they'd have to split it.
-Oh, that's right.
[ Laughter ]
Now, the other thing --
They would have to split it.
But I think The Strokes' drummer
should get just a little --
-Yeah!
-Yeah.
I think a little bit more, yeah.
-Just a little bit.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
But you do -- if you win,
you still gotta swear
you're coming to work
the next day, pal.
-Yeah.
-You know what? We all gotta --
-Nobody gets to take it off
just 'cause they win
the Mega Millions.
-Not good.
-Hey, you know what I think
is really funny?
And I want to stress this is a
choice our show makes, not you.
As I was introducing you
and I was saying things like,
"You know him from
'Forrest Gump'" and --
you know, that's helpful,
I think, for some actors,
but I don't think our audience
needed to hear those things.
I don't think, if I hadn't
mentioned "Forrest Gump,"
Tom Hanks would walk out,
and they'd be like,
"What do I know him from?"
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
You know, very kind of you.
It's very nice.
Thank you.
I have to blame home video
for the familiarity because,
you know, between --
between VHS machines and DVDs,
man, you get to --
you all grew up with me
one way or another.
-Yeah.
-Am I wrong?
"All right.
We're going out," and you know.
-That was a good era.
The VHS era
was a good time to get started.
-Wasn't it?
Wasn't it fabulous?
-Yeah.
It's crazy to me the idea of --
I just -- the amount of movies
I watched 15, 20, 30 times.
It was so easy for me.
Like, when you were growing up,
were there movies that
you watched over and over?
-But you had --
they had to land, you know?
They had to be on channel 5
or something like that.
And they were always
edited for commercials.
I remember the first time I saw
"The Maltese Falcon,"
it was only like 47 minutes long
because they just cut out
huge storylines, you know?
-Yeah.
-There was, what,
Archer and Spade?
There was no Archer in it,
was just Sam Spade.
So you had to deal with that.
But I -- The -- The --
There was a time
when I predicted
at, like, New Year's,
I predicted that, in the future,
we will all
just have a box on our TV,
and from that box,
we can watch anything we want.
We can watch documentaries
from 1952.
We can watch Edward R. --
We can all watch old episodes
of "The Dick Van --"
watch any movie that we want to.
And I thought it would be there.
I just didn't realize
it would each --
it was gonna cost us
10 bucks a month for five
different subscription services.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought it was,
"Well, you pay a buck
for each thing,
and that works out."
I didn't realize you would
have to have passcodes,
an accountant
that you had to pay for.
-Yeah.
-You know, nine different
remotes of menu, outputs,
you know.
-Do you ever have that --
I have this point with my kids,
who are obviously
a great deal younger than yours,
where they'll
get really excited.
I'll say,
"We're gonna show you a movie,"
and maybe, let's say,
it's on Disney+.
And we'll sit down,
I'll turn it on,
and it'll need
the password again,
and I will just say to them,
"It doesn't have
the movie you want."
-"We're not gonna have it."
[ Laughter ]
-"Disney+ is broken today."
-We can't --
"They decided
that you are not allowed
to watch this movie tonight."
-Yeah.
-"So let's play 'Clue.'"
-Yep, and there we go.
-Pull out the "Clue,"
and it's Colonel Mustard
in the study with the lead pipe.
-So you --
There's a wonderful scene
where you're teaching someone
to drive in this film.
Now, again, your kids are older.
You've gone through this.
Were you good --
Did you actually teach
your children how to drive,
and were you patient?
-Well, okay.
You've got youngsters,
so you put them on the lap.
You go to a big vacant lot.
-Uh-huh.
-You let them steer around,
and you control the pedals.
-Okay.
-Or, you know, you're coming up,
somebody's got a -- "Hey, it's a
quarter mile from here to there.
Sit behind, and I'll shift
for you and all that."
Then they get into where
they are sitting actually
in the driver's seat,
and you're riding shotgun,
and all you say is,
"What are you doing?
What are you doing?
What are you doing?"
-Yeah.
-"What are you doing?
No, no, no, no.
Easy, easy, easy. Easy!
Turn left, left, left!"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm absolutely --
No, turn that down."
That's the other thing.
"Turn it down!
Turn it down!"
-See, I'm glad to hear
you're like this because I feel
that is the future for me
just based on I'm trying
to teach them how to ski,
and the instruction
that I usually give
is something along
the lines of "Just ski!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Go down. Go down.
-Look, do what everyone else
here is doing.
-Pole, plant, pole, plant.
But, look, in all reality,
here's how we're gonna teach
our kids how to drive.
Sit down.
Enter your destination.
[ Laughter ]
Take a nap, and that's --
and they will get there
at some point.
-You -- a very cool thing
in this film,
you play Otto in present day.
Your son Truman...
-Yes, my son Truman.
-...your actual son Truman
plays you in the flashbacks,
and this is,
if not his first role,
certainly his first major role.
Were you excited for him?
-I was --
It's an intimidating process.
Marc Forster, who directed it,
he said, "Why do we have to have
a look-alike for you
to play the young" --
He's from Switzerland,
all right?
-Yeah, I got it.
I think we were worried.
We're like --
-He was not interrogating us.
He was actually suggesting
a better way
in order to make the movie.
"Can't one of your kids
come on and play you?
I think Truman
looks very much like you."
I said, "Well,
you'll have to talk to him."
So, he actually is a member
of the -- proud member of
Local 600 of the New York City
camera union.
So he actually --
he's actually --
he's actually loading film
on episodic TV today.
-Oh, my God.
-He's a renaissance dude.
And I said,
"Look, if you want to do this,
you know, understand
you got to fight
self-consciousness like crazy.
There's only one way to do it.
Show up, know your stuff,
let go, and ski!
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
"Why can't you ski?!"
-"Why can't you just ski?!"
And he did it okay.
-I thought he was great.
I have a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from the great Tom Hanks.